a great look in this movie get to wear
the flat cap yeah it's just such a
classic the flat cap is such a good
piece of clothing the only problem is I
think we have it here I think we have a
picture here of you in yeah that it's
like a classic hat that's hard to get
off
it's it's hard it's it's even harder to
steal and I I i managed to basically
steal one when we finished the movie by
just walking off set fully dressed on
the last day it's just getting into a
car and driving away so I actually I
brought I brought that flat cap this is
the one you wore in the movie this is
the one from the movie and this is I
would just like to demonstrate a point
if you wear this hat in England you look
like you could be a gangster like maybe
you're a fish and that you look good in
it you look like you could be a
dangerous spy that's like the European
thing you cannot wear one of these in
the United States and look cool it's
it's impossible like you it's it's I I
live in an area where there can be a lot
of hipsters you just look like a hipster
like that's that's just the way it goes
right would you like to try it on yeah I
will crew I will tell your client prove
your point right now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
like insert black iPhoto exactly no I
was born to wear a hat like this but I
look like I'm selling apples in the
Depression yeah that's that's a great
hat though yeah it's definitely worth
keeping don't don't tell Warner Brothers
that I stole that though yeah they're
out nineteen dollars alright man from
uncle classic TV show as I said and you
are paired with
Henry Cavill yep in this and and you
guys make a great team you have good
chemistry
you're in you're in love I thought you
might be in love because I saw this
promotional picture of the two of you on
a vest explain why you don't get to be
up front by the way that was my question
yeah because I I mean I ride a Vespa
everyday I've crossed a continent on a
Vespa so when I read in a script there
riding a vest but I just naturally think
I'll be driving this Vespa that's fine
I'm I love those old like px beautiful
yes was the to hundreds and all that
they're great pieces of machinery so we
get there on the day and they go Henry
you're in front army or and packing like
wait wait wait a minute
wait what the heck and it just got away
from me wrap it up enough of it--and I
ended up riding on the back there's no
way you have to kind of cuddle up with
them you know yeah yeah well you know
for safety you also have to put your
legs over his legs on the you know I
don't think you do I really don't think
you do
they didn't tell you that no I got to
break it to you that's not true these
hats are great too when you're asking
for a bank loan you can do so much with
one of these yep
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]